>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Stephen Winick: Welcome
to The Library of Congress.
My name is Steve
Winick, and I work here
at the American Folklife Center.
And we're conducting
an interview,
my co-interviewer is Mary Sue
Twohy from SiriusXM Radio,
and our guests are the
filmmakers who made the series,
American Epic, which
showed on PBS,
and I will let them
introduce themselves.
>> Allison McGourty: I'm Allison
McGourty, one of the writers
and producers of American Epic.
Originally from Scotland,
now living in Los Angeles.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And I'm
Bernard MacMahon, I'm director
and co-writer of the series.
>> Stephen Winick: So
we understand it took
about a decade for you
to go from inspiration
to the series, itself.
So the series explores the early
days of commercial recording,
particularly that burst
of activity that occurred
with 78 RPM disks all
across the country
and particularly roots music.
So can you tell us some
of the inspirations
for making this film?
>> Bernard MacMahon: The period
was of great interest to us
because in 1925 in
America the vast majority
of music was being sold to
wealthy people in the cities,
that was the audience.
And in '26 radio
took off in America
and record sales
dropped overnight.
All those people
in Chicago, Boston,
and New York started
listening to the radio.
So the record companies
thought we're going to be
out of business and they
came up with the novel idea
of why don't we try
and sell music
to poor people in rural America.
But they're not going
to be interested
in buying the show tunes and the
classical music and the big band
that we've been recording,
we're going to have
to record what they like.
So they devised a plan and that
was to advertise in local papers
across the whole of America
inviting people to come
and audition and
thousands of people came
and the auditions were
open to all Americans --
African Americans, Mexican
Americans, Hawaiians,
Cajuns, Native Americans.
And many of the guys, some
of the guys organizing the
sessions were song publishers
so they, like Ralph
Pierce, they insisted
that people bring their
own songs they'd written.
And they had just invented at
that time, the year before,
the first electrical
sound recording equipment,
the first microphone,
the first amplifier.
And they were recording
everything direct to disk
on a pulley-driven lathe
because they couldn't trust the
electricity to turn the
turntable at a constant 78 RPM.
And it took about
three-and-a-half minutes
for that weight to slowly
fall and hit the floor,
which is why today the pop
song is still three-and-a-half
minutes long.
And that explosion of recordings
is what our film is about,
it charts the journey of that
machine from New York to Oahu,
tells the story through
10 families
that participate in
those recordings.
And then for the fourth
film we rebuild that machine
from original parts
scavenged over 10 years
and it's the first time anyone
has seen it in almost 80 years.
And we asked contemporary
artists to record on it.
So I think the thing
that attracted us
about this story was it
hadn't been told before
and it combined all the things
about America that we loved --
its entrepreneurism, it's
incredibly rich culture,
its music and its
freedom of speech.
>> Stephen Winick: Great.
Well, thank you.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Can
you tell us a little bit
about your background before
creating American Epic?
>> Bernard MacMahon: I'll
pass that to you first.
>> Allison McGourty: Well, I
spent five years at the BBC
in Documentaries and Acquisition
and also the BBC World Service,
and prior to that at
Reuters Television,
so I was always interested
in storytelling
and history and journalism.
My dad was a newspaper man.
My sister was a journalist.
And then and I played
music growing up,
so I'd buy music as a kid.
I played the clarinet and
my sister played the flute.
And my dad would come
on holiday to America
and bring back records from
the Smithsonian and The Library
of Congress and Louisiana, so
I grew up listening to jazz
and Blues and old-time
American music.
And then when I started working
with Bernard in about 2003-04,
we started working
together on a record label
that then quickly segwayed
into a film company
with this project.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes, and I
just tagged along in her wake.
[laughter]
>> Stephen Winick: So
another interesting aspect
of this film is there
are some names
that people will recognize
associated with this film.
You have executive producers
who are T Bone Burnett,
Jack White and Robert Redford.
So how did those big names
essentially get involved
in this production?
>> Allison McGourty: Well,
I knew Bob Dolan's manager,
Jeff Rosen, and once Bernard
had gotten some really important
findings, some film
footage and photographs
that we knew had never been seen
before and published before,
we thought who better to
take it to than Jeff Rosen
who would essentially know
if we had a story here
and if it was worth telling.
So he was the first person
we went to and almost became
like a mentor to us in the
beginning and helped us.
So he's thought it
was a terrific story.
I made an introduction to BBC
Arena, to Anthony Wall there,
who came on as an executive
producer immediately
and was a super nice
guy, really helpful.
And he said you must take
this to T Bone Burnett,
so he made a phone call
and literally we find ourselves
the very next day flying
to Los Angeles for
the first time.
And we walked into the recorder
studio with our findings,
our folder and photographs
and walked into the studio
where there was two figures
leaning over a sound desk,
just finishing off,
tweaking a record.
And one was T Bone Burnett and
the other one was Elton John.
And Elton said, well, I've been
hearing about this project,
you mind if I sit in and listen?
So we went, oh, we'd
be delighted.
And then we sat down with
Elton and T Bone Burnett,
told the story of everything
we'd done, where we'd been.
At that point we
traveled from Cleveland,
Ohio to the Gulf of Mexico.
I've spoken to hundreds
of families.
And then Bernard,
take it from there?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
I presented this
film idea to them.
And I think Elton
said at the end of it,
he said that you should become
an executive producer on this,
right up your street, and
he said if you want me
to do anything just give me a
call, and passed on his numbers.
And then a few days later
I had a call from T Bone
and he said I've been talking
with a film guy for a few months
about he wants to do a
music related project
and I brought him
a lot of ideas.
He didn't seem interested
in any of them.
And I mentioned that
you had come
into the studio the other
day, he wants to meet you.
So we went down to Santa Monica
and it was Robert Redford,
and so I presented that to him.
>> Allison McGourty:
And he loved it.
He said this is, I think this is
America's greatest untold story.
And he gave us his
offices so we could kind
of finish our writing
there, so we essentially --
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
it was like, it was almost
because you're presenting
the whole idea of the film,
just like having a
screening in front
of a really tough audience
before you shot a frame,
you know?
And then when we came up with
the idea to actually do kind
of a proof of theory film, which
a full film is essentially --
I've always had an issue
with historical films,
where a feature is
based on supposition
of what may have happened.
And I think that the practical
employing of the ideas
or what took place
is really important
to understanding what
actually did take place.
And if you actually
do something,
for example you could a
film in 100 years' time
about the Apollo missions, but
if you were to actually rebuild
that rocket and go to the moon
there would be innumerable
things you'd learn about what
they must have done that aren't
in any books and that no
one alive would remember.
And that was the purpose of
the full film was to rebuild
that machine and then record on
it, and this was basically how,
the way we communicate
today at the end.
And every, all the sound
on these cameras here,
all that technology
comes from this machine
that no one had seen before.
Now, and so I felt we approached
Chad White, I think we wrote
to him because we thought he
would be a good person to come
and arrange and produce
those sessions.
I got the impression
he liked working
with analog here, which we did.
And so I think I wrote him an
e-mail, I think it was e-mail
and I dropped him a line,
I think I said something
like I have a photograph of some
house from 1929 and film footage
of Sleepy John Estes from 1938.
I think he wrote
back in a minute.
[laughter]
>> Stephen Winick:
It's a good book, yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes, yes, I
mean in his world that's catnip.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes, yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: So at the
very beginning of American Epic,
setting the scene in the
1920s, you hear the voice
of Robert Redford and he says,
when America first heard itself.
I love that phrase, can you
describe just what that means?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well, it's
coined by a dear friend of mine,
Charles Shala Mari @.
I said, can you sum-up
in one sentence what
this film is about?
I talked to him about
it many hours.
And he goes, let me think.
The first time America
heard itself.
And, of course, as always he
was completely on the money.
I like, I'm fascinated
and we both are
with the beginning of things.
I mean my first love was
early American cinema
where the language is being
invented, from the teens,
the '20s, the early '30s.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: As
you go through silent
and the early talkies,
because that's
where as a filmmaker you
learn the language of film.
And similarly in
music, this is the point
that everything is
being invented.
But really the phrase
comes from the fact that,
as I told Charles, up until
this point the vast majority
of America were not
communicating with each other.
The people living in the
Appalachians and in Louisiana
and in New Mexico, there
really is no communication.
We didn't have talking pictures,
there isn't coast-to-coast
radio, so these records
when they first appeared
were a method
that a woman picking cotton
in Mississippi could communicate
her ideas about her life
to the rest of America.
And it was the first time
in the history of the planet
that the poorest people in the
country were given a platform
on a nationally distributed
medium to express themselves.
And it was for entirely
commercial reasons,
they just wanted --
the guy, the record men
like Ralph Pier @
wanted to publish songs,
to own the words and the music.
So they insisted if you showed
up that you brought stuff
you'd written yourself
or at least did the
courtesy of adapting songs
and sticking a few of
your own words in it,
but basically it meant
for the first time all
of this incredible
autobiographical material.
The other factor
was that the crisis
that the record companies
were facing from radio
in the cities was so
serious that they needed
to move really quickly.
And so they were going
into territories,
Cajun being a perfect example,
where they couldn't understand
a word they were singing.
French people couldn't
understand what they were sang.
It's perfect French, but the
pronunciation is so strange.
But if they found after test
sessions there were a few
thousand people that
wanted to buy
that record they'd go back
again and record more.
And so they weren't editing
or affecting the content
of that material, they were
letting people do what they
wanted to do, and as long
as it sold they carried
on recording more of it.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And so,
yes, you had this freedom
of speech, this platform
for people to come out,
and these are people -- I mean
imagine if you were working
on a plantation or
Dockery and suddenly you're
in this tiny rural
community, you can't leave
and suddenly you're on a record
that is being distributed
around the whole
country and that people
to this day are still covering.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> If that isn't
freedom of truth
with speech I don't
know what is.
So that, I think that's why it's
the first time America heard
itself, and it actually
became a model
as to how the world heard
itself because the rest
of the world picked up on that.
>> Allison McGourty: And
they were writing songs
about their everyday
lives, their love lives,
local politics, stories of --
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
>> Allison McGourty: You know,
murders in their local town,
and it was a method of --
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
>> Allison McGourty: Sharing
their stories with the world.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And the
thing that's different is The
Library of Congress I mean
organized these, you know,
with John Lomax these
amazing recording trips.
These are noncommercial trips.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And
there's a huge amount
of value many years later of
being discovered from the songs
and things that were
recorded in these trips.
But this I think
was an even more
or a much more exciting thing
because these were commercial
recordings, people wanted these
to be heard by as many
people as possible.
They drew amazing adverbs
depicting the lyrics
of the songs.
The idea was to get this
in front of as many people,
and so it really meant that you
had Blues musicians listening
to country musicians,
country musicians listening
to Blues musicians,
Hispanic musicians listening
to Cajun musicians, everyone
was hearing everyone else
for the first time.
So it kind of -- it
basically made American music
and communication way richer.
>> Stephen Winick:
So is there a way
that particular challenges
involved
in making what's essentially
a visual film about sound?
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Almost impossible
because when we started there
was literally no archive at all.
I would say half -- the figure,
at least a third of the subjects
of our film there was no
known photograph of them
when we started, so that
meant there might be --
there may never be a
photograph of them.
We researched over 100 musicians
and groups that recorded
and whittled it down to
10 for the film, but, yes,
it was an enormous
detective job and so.
>> Allison McGourty: I remember
[inaudible] it looks here
like we've got a
really good radio show?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
[laughter]
>> Allison McGourty: Because
they were so [inaudible]
at that time of any of
the artists that we wanted
to tell the story of, so finding
enough material for Bernard
to make the film with.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes, so
it involved going through,
now I'd say probably, I would
say it's the biggest archive
in the world of material
relating to that era in terms
of the stills that
we have and the audio
and the private tape recordings
of these people speaking
and all the documentation,
along with the machine, itself.
But I think it started actually
as a kind of just a fascination
with trying to track down
some of the people, you know?
So I think one of them was,
I love this song Henry Lee
by Dick Justice, yes, and
so I started running --
I wanted to find him.
>> Allison McGourty: It was
on the charts at the time.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
it was in the charts.
>> Allison McGourty: Nick
Haive @ and PT Hovery @.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And so I
just started running stories
in all the -- he was believed
to come from West Virginia
so I just started running
stories in local papers
in West Virginia in the mining
communities because that was all
that was known of him, that
he might have been a miner
from West Virginia.
And then must have run about
six stories and I ran one
in the paper called The Logan
Banner and that resulted
in the editor calling
me and saying,
an old man has left his number,
and it was a guy called Bill
Williamson, a lovely man.
And he said, I know
Dick Justice's daughter
and she's quite elderly,
but here's her number.
And so I called her up and she
was really shocked to get a call
from England about her
dad, and she had no idea
that her dad's songs
had been covered
and were known around the world.
And she talked about him
going down in the mines
and how the musicians had
auditioned over the telephones
to record companies
because they couldn't get
to the standard auditions
everyone else went to.
And she said, she revealed she
only had one picture of him,
which was this embossed
plaque that's in the book.
And I think we arranged
a car to travel 100 miles
to this little community to
pick-up the picture and take it
to the nearest place
that could photograph it.
And I called Bill back to
thank him and he said, well,
my dad was also in the group
and they were called the
Williamson Brothers in Curry @,
and I knew them, they did the
first every John Henry recording
and he had all these
incredible stories.
And I think we started looking
for some more people and after
that Allison said they
should be made into a film,
this is the last time these
people are going to be alive
that can tell the story.
And then with our producer
and co-writer, Juke @,
we started in earnest
to really track
down the musicians we
personally felt the strongest
connection with.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes, I mean
one sort of heartbreaking moment
in the film is when
you're talking
to I guess it's Dick Justice's
son and he says, you know,
I never even knew that my
father had recorded these songs,
I knew he played the
piano and sang in church
but you'd think I would
have heard him sing one
of these songs at some point
in his life and I never did.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
yes, one of the things
that was most beautiful
about doing this film,
something I never expected,
was that we would be going
into communities and meeting
families that didn't know
about these records but they
knew about them playing music,
maybe locally, or that they
had an interest in music.
And so you would often sometimes
be playing these records
to people for the first time.
And so what was amazing
to me was
that we were bringing something
that they really wanted, too,
and they were giving all this
amazing memories and stories,
sometimes I think the
oldest interview was 104.
So we were catching these
people before they moved
on to the next world.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And that
was the most pleasing part was
to give all the research
that you had put together,
including the music to that and
then telling you the background
of what they knew about it.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
One of the themes
of American Epic is how
recording technology has changed
the world in terms of radio
for one and then of course,
you know, the technology
of recording music.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well,
yes, I mean that's --
the film is like
is multifaceted,
it deals with a lot of things,
I think is equally important
and the technology is as
important as the content,
in fact it defines the content.
And we in this moment here our
conversation is being shaped
by the limitations of being
recorded and sitting on a chair
with a mike and what have you.
And there the thing about this
recording machinery was this
machinery, when you work
with this recording system
it favors small groups,
vocal led groups
sound good on it,
and guitar bass things
particularly.
The microphone likes it.
So our sense of it is that the
emergence of the small group,
be it a popular group, a country
group or even a jazz group is
because that was sadly
given that machine.
And whereas opera and that
kind of music was much bigger
in the acoustic era when you
were singing and shouting
into a horn because you
needed huge amounts of volume.
This, in '26 when this machine
was invented it allowed you
to capture very subtle
nuances, and so performers
that were singing very quietly
and performing delicately
could be captured on it.
And then people actually
started to exploit
that that sounded really good
and the intimacy of this.
And so, yes, I think it
fundamentally shaped the way all
music is to this day and now
recording technology that's
followed on from it.
But most really hardcore
engineers consider the
technology today in
many ways inferior,
in recording technology
the purer it is,
the less parts you're moving
through between the
signal coming in
and the end product the better
and this is very simple.
So people that are really big
audio buffs would love this
amplifier for its simplicity.
But, yes, I think it shaped
the way we communicate.
And this is the really
interesting thing in relation
to say what we're
filming here today,
Hollywood had been resisting
for years putting sound
on motion pictures but
they relented in '27 with
and I think one of the
factors in this was
that this machine was putting
electrical sound recordings all
around America in the
cheap, in the poorest homes,
where the people
would listen to them
on little wind-up
record players.
And I think this amongst other
things is one of the factors
that allowed Western Electric
to go back to Hollywood and go,
how can you not have
sound on talking pictures?
You have the whole
country listening
to electrical sound
recording, you know?
So it's impossible to even
overstate how important this
machine is to how we
communicate today.
>> Stephen Winick: So you talked
about the small group and one
of those sort of
iconic small groups
from that era was
the Carter family.
So what do you think is --
there've been a lot of books
and other things written
about that particular group,
what do you think is your take
on the Carter family that's
different in this film?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well,
that's it's a female group.
We're not taking anything away
from A.P. Carter in the film,
but if you listen to interviews
with Sarah and Maybelle,
and we've been through
everything that exists as far
as we know, they found a lot
of songs themselves and a lot
of the early repertoire
was theirs.
And essentially it's
a female duo,
I mean A.P. is often no present
on a lot of the recordings.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
And they often joke
that he would just
wander off in the middle
of a recording session and
just look out the window.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And so
the Carter family struck me
as a female group and
that in itself in 1927
and in the country medium
is an unusual thing.
And it's a pretty immense
produced female group,
it's like a strong
powerful female group.
So I think that was the
shading on the story.
I'm now literally -- the way
we approached these stories was
just we wanted to
let the families
that knew these people
tell these stories
in their own words.
And our sense was that
historians in places
like New York, some of who may
have never have visited the
Appalachians, like my Kentucky
friends always tell me it should
be pronounced, there would be
all these theories and concepts
about what would happen.
And so after we traveled
extensively
in America we felt
the appropriate thing
to let families themselves
tell the stories.
And my feeling was
I just wanted --
we just wanted the viewers
to feel what we felt was
when we spent time
with these people.
And if you're with the son
of somebody that has grown
up their whole life
with this person,
not only do they have a lot of
their father or their mother
in them, they often
speak like them,
they often think like them.
And this is the closest
way for another person
to touch the beating
heart of that story,
when that person
is long past away.
And so our sense was
let them tell the story.
And so really the stories
as they are really how they
see them is an accumulation
of how they depict that.
And so I think our sense of
the Carter family story was
that it was very much that he
was the driving force in terms
of getting them the session,
but it was a female group
essentially in terms
of records and its performance.
>> Stephen Winick: Interesting.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: How did
you find the connection
between Elder Birch
and Dizzy Gillespie?
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Want to do this?
>> Allison McGourty:
Yes, but you do it.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well,
all these stories come
out of a particular record.
And I think we become --
if you saw a beautiful girl
or a handsome dashing man
walking along the street you'd
become curious about
them, you know?
And it's that kind of, it's
the music that draws you in.
And so if you're interested,
I heard this record,
My Heart Keeps Singing, and I
just thought it was one of --
just this beautiful,
beautiful record.
And I thought if we do a gospel
piece in the film we have
to put this song, My Heart
Keeps Singing, in there.
It was only a few years later
that Taj Mahal explained
to me why I loved that song.
I grew up in a West Indian
neighborhood in South London.
And he said, this comes
from Saint Kitts this song,
this is a Caribbean song or
this is a West Indian Song.
If you didn't know the song, he
says, it's the style of singing.
And I listened to when I grew up
as a child listening to Reggae,
and I went, oh, my God,
that's why I like this.
It sounded like the songs that
my Jamaican friends would play,
their parents would play.
And so I love this song and
this voice in me said we need
to put this song on the film,
but we need to at least know
something about who made it.
And all that we had was
on the record label,
it said Elder J.E.
Birch and Congregation.
And I remember asking around,
all the different people I could
find that were into gospel music
and nobody had heard of Birch.
They knew him, they
knew the name,
but no one knew anything
about him.
And so I went to the Sony
archive in the basement
of Sony Records and went
through their recording ledgers.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
What was that like?
I mean did you have to go
in an elevator, down floors?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
it's deep in the basement.
>> Allison McGourty:
Yes, exactly.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And, yes,
and it is these rows and rows
of boxes containing
the recording ledgers
of each session, so
at these sessions back
in the teens even there would
be someone with a typewriter
that would be typing up
the songs that were done
and making notations about it.
>> Stephen Winick: And thank
God that they did that.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes, and
eventually I found in this box,
Birch, and it listed the songs
and there was just one piece
of information in the corner, it
just said Turola @ misspelled,
North Carolina I think it
said, South Carolina I believe.
But anyway and there was no
indication what that meant,
often it was a place, and
there was no indication
that Birch had come from
there but it was all we had.
And so I think one of the
reasons that doing this
for The Library of Congress
is appealing to me is I want
to say this, this
project was only possible
because of librarians because
anytime we found an obscure town
the first thing we'd do
is call the town library.
And librarians are the most
universally helpful people
at trying to find the
person in the town
that might know what
you're trying to find.
And librarians also seem to
get very curious about the call
from England about a member
of their community
they've heard of.
So that's a big -- I just
want to say that if it wasn't
for the librarians of America
there wouldn't be an American
Epic because so many of
things were unearthed
because of a genial elderly
old librarian that kind of --
but never heard of him.
[laughter] And let's
find out about him,
somebody in London knows
about him, you know?
So anyway we went to Turola
and nobody knew anything
about Birch, and eventually
we were told to speak
to an African-American
town elder.
And we went over to
the poorer part of town
and we met this lovely
man, Ted Bradley.
And Bradley remembered Birch.
>> Allison McGourty: He
was lovely, too, wasn't he?
>> Bernard MacMahon:
He's a gorgeous man.
>> Allison McGourty: He just
had the shine about him.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
He really did, yes,
he's one of the great
flowers of America, you know?
Wonderful fellow.
>> Allison McGourty: We'd
been there for two weeks.
We first, it was our evening
before we were leaving we were
having a farewell dinner and
we failed in our mission,
we hadn't found any leads.
And we walked into
this restaurant
that was only open a couple
of nights and somebody put us
in touch with one of the
people that worked there,
made a phone call and
said, oh, you need to stay,
this person knows him.
And so we extended our flight
and that was the next day we
went over to the other side
of the tracks and
met Ted Bradley.
So it was just in
the nick of time.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Yes, and so --
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
And he knew Birch?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
and he'd gone to that church
and he described that
the church was this kind
of raw looking affair and
that he was not a sanctified
church member.
And so he said he would have
been punished by his parents
if they'd known as a
little boy he was sneaking
into this church, but the music
was so good he was drawn to it.
And he mentioned that
the music was so powerful
that white people
after they had been
to their church would all sit
in their cars and the trees
around the little wooden Triumph
church that birch had built
with his bare hands and listen
to the music all afternoon.
And so it brought the white
and black members of
the town together.
And Birch was one of the people
that set-up the NAACP
in South Carolina.
And Turola became quite an
emancipated town and I think
that church was a big
factor in spreading,
connecting the races together.
And so but we still didn't
have a photograph of Birch,
and we were then introduced
to Ernest Gillespie
and he was a friend of Ted
Bradley and Ernest had also
as a little boy snuck into
that church and listened
to all the stomping
and the shouting.
And he, when we met,
he said, well,
you know who was really
influenced by this music,
it was my cousin who lived
next door, Dizzy Gillespie.
And he pulled out this, he
pulled out this autobiography
by Dizzy, it was
long out of print
and no one has ever seen
this connection in there,
and said look in
here and he talked
about Birch's church being
the big inspiration for him
and going to hear, that's where
he understood about rhythm
and melody and spiritual
transport through music
through going to that church.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes,
I think that was kind
of a really great moment in this
film because it really is true
that Elder Birch's recordings
are known among the sort
of record officiants
and, of course,
Dizzy Gillespie is
revered among everyone
who studies American music
and the connection was there
to be made but nobody made
it before because he wrote
about Elder Birch in his book.
So it was great that you
found that and were able
to bring that out in the film.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Exactly,
yes, and I think it's just --
so I think what I liked
about the story and the story
for the audience was that in
your own communities there are
those little pieces of string
that if you start pulling
them could easily lead
to a story like this.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And
they're all over America,
and this is an example of
a guy that's just known
for this one record
but it transpired he was a
pivotal influence upon the most
important musicians
of the 20th Century.
Yes, I think so, and the Joseph
Kekuku story is the same.
>> Stephen Winick: Well, I was
just going to ask about that
because the Kekuku story has
been somewhat known among
ethnomusicologists
and the like and many
of them don't actually think he
invented the slide in the sense
that it's part of African music
and so a way for it to get
to the Blues that's more obvious
than Hawaiian music would be
just through African roots,
although obviously the style
of playing steel guitar
or something that he did invent.
So what is your take on that
and on the slide question?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well, it
doesn't, the steel bar played
on the guitar, but it doesn't
exist in any form that I'm aware
of before he started playing it.
And the earliest record I
found of it was in the '30s,
a musician called C.S. Delorno
@ wrote in a track on a guitar
and banjo, published in Britain,
and he recalls Kekuku talking
about when he came up with the
idea and how he propagated it.
And that's by far the
earliest writing about that.
And then the first
ever book in the teams
of slide guitar playing is --
or steel guitar playing
is by Myrtle Stumpf @,
and she was one of
Kekuku's pupils.
So I'm just, I'm not aware
of that and I'm not aware
of anything that proceeds it
that is played in
a similar fashion.
And then the other thing to
remember as well with this is
that there's no way to be
absolute about these things,
and I think that's a kind
of a desire of historians is
to be an absolute truth.
Oftentimes you can
have situations
where two people are working
on the same scientific
problem solving or theory
and on opposite ends of the
world, and one may popularize
that theory before the other.
But in this instance
it's pretty clear
that after the World's Fair
in San Francisco there were
extensive tours organized all
across America with Toots
Paka that Kekuku played with.
And the newspaper, if you go
through the newspaper cuttings
through the teens you can see
this tour going everywhere
and it's a big sensation.
There's no musician that we
worked with that we tracked
down that has as much
publicity as Kekuku has,
which is incredible given
how until this film came
out he was largely
completely forgotten.
But that tour was organized by a
big theater promoter at the time
and it meant that
thousands and thousands
of people heard that
musical style.
And Kekuku toured Europe
and around the world.
He played in the Bird
of Paradise show.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And I
believe that is how people heard
that music and I think
that's how that playing got
to the delta, people in the
delta heard those, that --
when the Toots Paka's group
toured there they heard
that music and wanted
to do it themselves.
And really if you look at it,
if you see someone playing it
it's not that difficult to do.
If you play guitar and you
hear this incredible sound
that is made simply just by
flipping the guitar on its side
and then running a belt
across it I mean most people
or musicians would go
back and go let me figure
out how we did that, you know?
And it wouldn't take very
long to realize you just need
to raise the strings up
and get a smooth object.
So I think really those
tours are what propagated it
around America.
And then I'm not aware
of any other musical unit
that was spreading that idea.
Because by the early '20s, you
know, Hawaiian music was one
of the most popular forms of
music in America, so there's no,
any evidence whatsoever
that points to anyone other
than to Kekuku as being the
person that propagated that.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
So I probably did this
backwards, but I should say
that the Kekuku story
is about Joseph Kekuku,
a great Hawaiian
guitarist who is said
to have created what we
call Hawaiian steel guitar
and also steel guitar in
general coming through that
and that's I think undisputed.
The only question among
ethnomusicologists has been
whether another form of slide
playing existed with the guitar,
which would have been
essentially bottleneck slide
playing on one string as opposed
to across all the strings,
and that's something
that ethnomusicologists
kind of argued about.
So I probably did
that backwards,
I should have had you tell
the Kekuku story first
and then just bring
up that point,
but it is in a way a minor
point in the sense that all
that you are saying
is it is undisputed
that he started what we
think of as steel guitar.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
That would be fascinating
if someone presented a recording
or serious documentation showing
somebody using a smooth bar
on an upturned guitar
prior to Kekuku.
If such documentation exists
it'd be fascinating to see it.
There's no doubt he invented --
I've always found
the distinction
between the steel guitar
played on all the strings
and the bottleneck, I don't
see a huge difference, myself,
between them in terms of
the concept is the same.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: But, yes,
I'm just not aware
of anyone doing it.
Who do they cite as
being the person that --
>> Stephen Winick: Well,
essentially what they cite is
the fact that slides are used
in African music on a whole
range of stringed instruments,
including musical bows, and
the diddly bows were known
in the south, and so a
more obvious way of getting
to the bottleneck
slide in southern,
African-American music would
have been straight from Africa
as opposed to it coming in
from Hawaii, but there's no way
to prove it because, as you
say, I don't think any recording
of it, specifically a
guitar, being played
with a slide exists before
Joseph Kekuku's recordings, so.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
and all the countries,
which is in the same regions
is clearly Hawaiian based
of the steel guitar.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: What was it
like to hear the slide
guitar on the recording?
You had mentioned
something about it just,
it being a very good experience.
>> Allison McGourty:
Oh, it was wonderful.
And Bernard discovered this
record with Joseph Kekuku,
I think one of the earliest
recordings, I think it was
from the late teens, wasn't it?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well, as
Delorno mentions in his article
that Kekuku had made,
he'd appeared on records
with this group called
Layton and Johnstone,
which were an English,
African-American group that went
over to Britain and
started making these kind
of musical numbers,
all dressed in tuxedos,
and the King was a
big fan of theirs.
And they said that he played
on three of their records,
and everything he had said
in his article I
checked out panned out.
And so I went and I
searched these records
and it took something like
two years to find one of them,
they were the hardest
records to find.
The internet is saturated with
the Layton and Johnstone records
from Britain, but
not those titles.
And eventually one
showed up and we dubbed it
and halfway through,
the slide guitar,
which is kind of incredible.
So in the film we
brought that to Oahu
and because no one has ever
heard Joseph Kekuku play
and played it to the
family for the first time,
so the first time anyone in Oahu
had heard what it sounds like.
>> Allison McGourty: And
to answer your question
about what it felt like, when
you hear the music in the place
that it came from it touches
you differently, it feels right.
So it sounds different in
Hawaii than it does in London,
and we noticed that
everywhere we went
with all the different
kinds of music in the place
where the music was
created you can tell,
you can sense it's right,
that's where it belongs.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
Wow, so the landscape
and where it originated
was really truly important?
>> Allison McGourty: Yes,
absolutely, yes, so the rhythms.
>> Bernard MacMahon: We
called it geographonics.
>> Allison McGourty: Yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
That that music sounds
like the place it comes from
and you can hear the landscape
in the music and you can also
only truly understand the music
when you go to the
place it was made.
So as a Londoner you only ever
really truly understand jazz,
modern jazz when you're sitting
in a New York taxicab
and it's playing.
That was the first time
I understood jazz truly,
I loved it but I
didn't understand it.
And the nature of
American music,
the Hopi songs I was fascinated
by them, but when I went
to Hopi, which is one
of the strangest places
on the planet I've ever visited,
those songs certainly sounded
like pop songs when I was there.
I know they're scared songs,
but they sounded catchy to me,
and once I heard them at Hopi
I started humming the songs.
>> Stephen Winick: Interesting.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
And I didn't,
I couldn't even follow
the melody line
of the songs originally,
they disinterested me,
but once I'd been there in that
geography and playing that song
as we drove around or wandered
around Hopi I was like, oh,
this basically sounds
like this landscape.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
That's fascinating.
>> Allison McGourty: Yes,
[inaudible] talks about that
as well in the other film when
he talks about the Cajun music
and the [inaudible] that the
music reflects the environment
in which it comes from.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes, Cajun
music, which is a little strange
to other people's ears is
really commercial when you're
in Louisiana because it
sounds exactly like the place.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: So a
little weird, a little strange,
going everywhere and swamps
and strange things
crawling out of them.
This slightly odd music sounds
exactly right there, you know?
Yes, and I guess that --
>> Stephen Winick: Oh, yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Yes, so I think a lot
of art is mirroring
our environment
and it's entirely affected
by the environment,
kind of responding, and
so it's best I think.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: San Antonio,
Texas, that became kind of a hub
for record companies
in the 1920s,
and that is where Lydia Mendoza
@ and her family first recorded.
You actually met with some of
her relatives and got to visit
with them, can you
tell us a little bit
about that experience?
>> Bernard MacMahon:
The Hernandez family,
they're Lydia's grandchildren,
and they live --
yes, they live in San Antonio.
And the house, they're
wonderful, it's Roger and Ann --
>> Allison McGourty:
Ann McKinney.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
And their dad, Fernando.
And the house is almost partly
like a shrine to
their grandmother.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Wow.
>> Bernard MacMahon: So
they had more photographs
and memorabilia related to her
than I think almost
any other family we met
in researching this film.
And she had obviously been this
huge larger than life figure,
and when you were with them they
almost spoke in hushed tones
about her as if she could
walk in the door at any moment
and go, what are
you saying about me?
[laughter] So she was a
woman that cast a long shadow
and I really like
that, that's why I kind
of wanted the audience, I hoped
the audience got a little sense
of that in the films,
was this woman,
she felt like she
just left the house
and she died a long time ago.
And so I found them really kind
of really wonderful
people to hang out with.
And I think I like the
idea, I love the idea
of all these different stories
being next to each other
because I think American
culture,
that's what makes American
culture really exciting is the
Hispanics mix, the Cajuns
mix, the Native Americans,
the African-Americans
and the Hawaiians.
So kind of it was like it
was almost like being hit
by this emotional Tsunami
traveling from these places
because when you arrived to film
it would often be the result
of many meetings, many
phone conversations,
a really close relationship
built with these people
and then this explosion of them
telling the story on camera.
And you'd be just
inundated with all this stuff
and these new things they'd
found, and then you'd go
on to the next place
and into their world.
>> Stephen Winick: Well, one
thing you might find cool is
that Lydia Mendoza performed in
this building in 1977 or '78,
I can't remember the exact
year, but she performed
in the Coolidge Auditorium,
which is right in the building
where you're sitting here.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
This [inaudible] was
she here for that?
>> Stephen Winick: It may have
been, yes, it may have been.
>> Bernard MacMahon: The Jimmy
Fox @ inaugural, so, yes,
that was -- yes, she was -- I've
forgotten the specific question
about -- what was it about?
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Well, we
were just kind of talking
about how it was
meeting with her family
and you described
that, but I also want
to know about the dresses?
She made her dresses and
did you see one on premise?
>> Allison McGourty:
Yes, she made the dresses
and the family talked about how
there was always sequins all
over the place.
And I met the family
again this year when we --
when I went down to San Antonio
for the ARSC Annual Meeting,
and we invited the family in to
talk and they got to see the cut
of her story for
the very first time.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Oh, neat.
>> Allison McGourty: With
the audience at that meeting,
so that was wonderful and that
brought a tear to their eyes,
but they were just so thrilled
to have their family honored
like that and have
people remember, yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Yes, that's the best bit
of the film is screening
it for the families
and then getting the approval
of the people that it's about.
I mean actually as a
filmmaker that's the only,
that's the thing you
really care about is
that they think it's
true, you know?
And actually those families
are very, they're very open,
you know, the story doesn't
have to be sugarcoated,
there's lots of tough
bits to it.
>> Allison McGourty: But
what was it like in Sedona,
I didn't come to that
screening with the Hopi
when you got their blessing?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Oh,
yes, so I had invited Lee,
who is in the film, who is --
>> Allison McGourty: Suvant @.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes, and
he's a very, very senior Hopi
and to come -- they
were having --
the last screening at the Sedona
Film Festival, and I thought,
well, let's do this, this
will be an opportunity
to show Lee the film
before it airs.
And we go to this theater
and I'm expecting it to be
like 20 people there
or something.
And it's absolutely packed and
the film director says, oh,
we invited Lee to a few things,
but he never comes,
he won't come surely.
And he shows up and he's
very friendly and goes in.
I was sitting next to
him and the film starts
and I was thinking thank
God I put the Hopi story
at the beginning of this film
because [laughter] I don't want
to wait for 40 minutes
for his reaction.
And I think about 10 minutes
through he started laughing
at something out loud and
then he kind of leaned over
and tapped me on
the arm, like this.
And the screening was up there
and it was a very kind,
wonderful reception.
And then someone was asking
us questions and they ran
up to the back of the theater
and put a mike in front of Lee.
And this is obviously a
very big deal he'd shown up,
apparently he doesn't
show up at these things.
And I said, what
do you think of it?
And he goes I think
it's wonderful
and I give it my full
blessing, you know?
That was a very meaningful
moment.
>> Stephen Winick: Sure.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And he
was very kind, he let us use --
we showed him all the footage
we were planning on using
and gave his permission to
use it, and so it was --
because I said, look,
we've found some amazing
things you see in the film.
The performance on the steps
of Congress I said are we okay
to use this, it's your call?
>> Stephen Winick: Where
did that footage come from?
>> Bernard MacMahon: We,
this was like another
detective story,
like the whole film I suppose.
I had basically -- I was
fascinated in this record,
it was one of the first
electrical sound recordings
of Native American music and I
knew a tiny bit about the Hopi
and I know a very little
more since I did that film.
>> Stephen Winick: And
it was called the Hopi?
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Hopi Indian Chanters.
>> Stephen Winick: Okay,
and the title of the?
>> Bernard MacMahon: The
title of the record was Chant
of the Eagle Dance and
Chant of the Snake Dance.
And the Snake Dance is the
most sacred Hopi ritual
and that is used to
bring rain to the desert,
so it is essential that
song is for their survival.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
And it's a private --
>> Bernard MacMahon: Entirely
secret, private ceremony.
So a friend of ours flew us
to Flagstaff when we found
out about a Hopi convention
that was happening in Flagstaff
where all the Hopi
elders were meeting
to discuss preserving
their language.
They were worried that the
younger generation may stop
speaking Hopi.
So we went there and met them
and I met a Hopi called Satilla,
and I played him the songs.
And he said, well, that's
not the Snake Dance,
that's the Eagle Dance, and the
Eagle Dance is not the Eagle
Dance, that's the Buffalo Dance.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: So
they're inaccurate labelings
on the Victor recordings
for the title of the --
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well,
they're entirely what the Hopi
wanted Victor to call them.
[laughter] But the
film, the one thing
about the Hopi is they don't
feel the rest of the world needs
to know their business,
it doesn't really help
stuff for them, you know?
So try to respect that
and it's a little message
that we don't have to
look under every rock,
you should let certain
people be if they want to be,
let them do their thing.
They're certainly not in an area
where they're bothering
anybody, you know?
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
They've chosen to be
in the toughest place on
the planet or one of them.
So, yes, so I wanted --
so I started searching
around for this
and eventually I tracked
down that Billingsley @ was a
white guy that traveled the Hopi
and he had befriended
them and lived the Hopi,
and Congress were attempting
to ban the Snake Dance
and they felt that if they could
ban the Snake Dance it would
basically pull the
heart out of Hopi.
And that tribe, which was
resistant to being integrated,
were being messed
with, they felt,
Lee said if they could break
the religion they'll break
the tribe.
And so they moved in Congress
to get the Snake Dance banned
because it involves carrying
snakes in the mouths of dancers
and they argued that
it was barbaric.
It's not barbaric to snakes
or anything, it's just,
as Lee puts it, it was a
mechanism that they saw
of destabilizing the tribe.
And so Billingsley,
rightly or wrongly,
decided that if he brought
the Hopi and toured America
with them and showed
their rituals.
It would bring an acceptance
that these rituals weren't
a threat to anybody.
And so they went to Victor and
made recordings, which I think
to make them more
commercial they wanted it
to be the Snake Dance,
but obviously no white people
had any idea what they were
listening to.
And so there was another dance.
And then they brought them to
Congress like a few weeks later,
so they were on this tour.
And I found newspaper reports
of them dancing on the steps
of the Capitol, and so really
essentially it was purely a gut
instinct that there might have
been a newsreel camera there,
and zero showed up
until we eventually went
through some archives in North
Carolina that had thousands
and thousands of feet of
unused Fox movie time newsreel.
This is where the
unedited newsreels went,
things that weren't
cut into newsreels.
And buried in there was footage
from a Fox movie time newsreel.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
That's amazing.
>> Stephen Winick:
That is amazing.
>> Bernard MacMahon: So
it was just an instinct,
and I think someone might
have been there with a --
actually I found a still,
a picture of the crowd
and the crowd was huge,
which I show in the film.
I found that and that
in itself was a eureka.
And then looking at it
after it's like it has
to be a camera, a movie camera.
And that was still silent film,
but I think the camera there.
I was going through the
thing with a magnifying glass
and I couldn't see a
movie camera, but yes.
>> Stephen Winick: Did you
shout when you found it?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Oh, my God,
and the footage you
see is stunning.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
It is stunning.
>> Stephen Winick: It sure
is, it's amazing footage.
>> Bernard MacMahon: I
didn't tell Leo I was going
to show it --
>> Stephen Winick: Yes, it looks
like it was shot
yesterday except
for being black-and-white.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Because
it had never been used
since it was developed,
it had never been
in a projector before.
It had never been transferred.
So a lot of the footage in the
film is like that, it's unseen.
And so, yes, and so I thought
when I interviewed Lee I
had never even told him
about the footage, I thought
I'll just show it, I'll show him
that and see what he thinks, and
like he was very moved by it.
He was obviously shocked because
he'd heard about the event,
but he didn't think they'd
actually done the Snake Dance
there, he thought they
had done a fake ceremony.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Thinking
that white people wouldn't
know the difference.
And so he was moved to tears
when he saw they actually had
to do, they did the ceremony.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Wow.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And so
he felt that was something
that the rest of
the world should see
that the Hopi shouldn't have
had to do that in order just
to continue doing something that
they'd been doing for so long.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes, so
one of the connections for me
that was really interesting just
because it's not something you
would necessarily think of was
to find out that Charlie
Mussel White @ was mentored
by Will Shade @ of
the Memphis Jug Band.
[laughter] So talk about Jug
Band music a little and how
that sort of dominates
part of that first film?
>> Bernard MacMahon: I love
it, I mean I'm obsessed
with the Memphis Jug Band.
I see the Memphis Jug Band as
like the first black pop group.
I think they're absolutely
brilliant.
I love everything about them.
That was one story that was like
we're doing then, I don't care
if there's nothing, we don't
know anything about Will Shade,
we're doing this group, people
have to hear this music.
And it so obviously is
a precursor of R and B,
everything seemed that.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Allison McGourty:
Even Skiffle.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
absolutely, yes, yes, I mean.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Absolutely.
>> Bernard MacMahon: I
mean that's what Skiffle,
they called it Skiffle
back in the '20s.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: I thought
Skiffle was something my mom
used to like, you know?
But, yes, that's
where that comes from.
And we all know the Beatles
were a Skiffle band or some
of them were originally.
Yes, so Will Shade.
So then the question was how do
I tell the story, there were no,
there were like two pictures
of Will Shade in existence
and pretty much nothing else.
There are a few fragments of an
interview that Paul Oliver did,
but he really was
for someone that was
like a huge big music
selling artist with masses
of records being covered by all
these people there was very,
very little known about him.
And so I tramped with Allison
around Memphis repeatedly trying
to find anybody that knew him.
I knew from the Center's
records,
I found in the Center's records
that he didn't have children,
so that really makes
things very difficult.
And there was nobody
alive that remembered him,
even though he died in 1996.
So something happens in Memphis,
things get swept away unlike
any other city I've been
to in America and you
really got the sense
after three visits
even though in '66,
which in historical terms
not long ago it felt
like this is gone, this has just
been it's like Katrina has come
in and just swept this
away, any memory of this.
All the houses where they
lived were knocked down,
the area he lived in.
And so I was literally about
to give up until my friend,
Garth Cartwright, an
author in Britain said,
I think Charlie Mussoway @,
a friend of mine, knew him.
And I was like it just
seemed too good to be true
that a well-known musician
would actually know this dude,
after we tramped over the city.
And I called Charlie and
he went, my God, yes,
two guys were my big
influences in Memphis, you know,
it was Will Shade
and Elvis Presley.
So Charlie would be
going to this really,
really poor neighborhood and
learning to play from Will Shade
and then he would go to
a fun fair late at night
that Elvis Presley
had rented out.
And I just thought,
wow, the dichotomy
between those two
musical worlds, you know?
[laughter] But, yes, so
Charlie, and I just --
it felt to me like
it was a wonderful,
that became a story
of mentorship.
So a lot of these stories
are emotional stories
and the music is emotional.
People can take all this
information now and go
into much detailed
historical treatise
and pull all the bits together,
but to me I love the story
of this music being
handed down to this boy
that was visiting his house.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: And
he was, he was a boy
when he first met Will Shade.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
He was, yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Tell us
about where you filmed Charlie
when he was talking
about Will Shade?
>> Bernard MacMahon: All the
people in the film are filmed
on location in a place that is
very significant for stories,
there are no interviews
that are like we are,
just to give us a backdrop.
Although we are in a
space, not like a studio.
>> Allison McGourty:
Lydia was here.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
this is a perfect a place.
But, yes, you're brought into
a studio and are interviewed.
We want to interview
Charlie in a club
that Will Shade would have
played in on Beale Street
and all the clubs had been
knocked down on Beale Street,
Pee Wee's, [inaudible] the
Monarch, which was owned
by Jim Canane @,
who was a big kind
of mafioso type guy in Memphis.
Old Jim Canane is the place.
In fact, there's even
a song on our box set
by Robert Wilkins called Old Jim
Canane about going to that club
and sniffing cocaine,
very rough.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
And Will Shade
and the Memphis Jug
Band were the house band
and we found the
building, and we peered
into the building it
was a police station.
[laughter]
>> Allison McGourty: The irony.
>> Bernard MacMahon: But
for some strange reason the
downstairs of the club
was largely untouched
with the same walls and brick,
and the police stored
their bicycles there.
And the upstairs floor was
the actual police station.
When we went into the police
station they were so bemused
and intrigued of what the
history of the club was
that they let us basically empty
out the entire police contents
of the ground floor and set-up
a makeshift studio there.
So, yes, we filmed Charlie
on the very club floor
that Will would have played in
in the '20s, yes, in the '30s.
So, yes, all the films, all
the places are shot like that,
you know, in the church
at Sharore @, on the steps
of Maybelle Porter's Chop House.
So really just as a filmmaker
your hope is to bring people
to the place on a film where
the story happened to be talking
to the family and just to have
a sense, to create a sense
of what it would be like if you
went and met, spent an afternoon
with Dale Jet @,
sitting on his porch,
and he's telling you the story,
and he's effectively bringing
out the photographs and the film
clips and showing them to you.
And that's all we wanted to
do was to create that sense
of you going into the
place where it happened.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: With the
people that knew those people,
their blood, and they're
telling that story.
And if they don't
have blood, you know,
they're protegees, you know?
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Exactly.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And
so, yes, and so I think
with Charlie it's emotive
when you're in that place,
when you're in that room, the
emotions are strong, you know?
And you could feel it
in the way he talked,
the way he sings his song.
He knows that Will was
in that room, you know?
>> Mary Sue Twohy: At one
point he breathes in deeply
and just sort of
takes in the air
of the room and all its history.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: And
completely enjoys that moment.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
it was absolutely real,
history did that, you
know, he was like --
he knew what it meant
to be in there.
And I think it was we had a very
funny moment, I really wanted
to put in the film but it just
couldn't fit, was we wanted
to go and visit Will
Shade's grave
and have Charlie leave a
memento for Will on the tomb,
a harmonica or some such.
And so we get to the cemetery
where Will is buried
outside Memphis
and there is yellow tickertape
around the whole cemetery
and just mountains of
police cars piled up.
And we're like what
went on here?
And they go, the
cemetery is a crime scene.
[laughter] And Charlie
turned to me and went,
only in Memphis it
would be a crime scene.
And I said to the policemen,
I said what do you
mean a crime scene?
He goes, well, the owners
of the cemetery have been doing
illegal things with the bodies,
removing them, reburying them.
>> Stephen Winick: I remember
this story, it's crazy.
>> Bernard MacMahon: I said when
do you think they'll open it?
You know, it was like we
expect this to be a crime scene
for another couple of years for
him to figure out all the stuff,
like digging up corpses.
And Charlie stood
outside on camera
and played his harmonica song
to Will, outside the cemetery,
and he just said -- he looked up
and he said this is a Will Shade
joke, he said he didn't come
and see me enough when I was
alive, he certainly ain't going
to come and see me
when I'm dead.
>> Stephen Winick: But that
relationship between Charlie
and Will Shade kind of
brings up another issue
that I think is a sort of
an undercurrent to a lot
of the film, but you don't
get very explicit about it
which is the question of race,
that there was probably
more musical interplay among
African-Americans and white
Appalachian folks, for example,
then is evident from
the records, themselves,
and yet there's also all
kinds of racial tension
and racial issues going on.
And I mean an example that
came up in the film was
when Mississippi John Hurt
wanted to hear his record
and his neighbor
played it for him
and he stood outside the window
and listened to it playing
through the window rather than
just going into her house,
as would be normal now.
So how do you feel that
the story of race is told
through this music, as well?
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Well, the records are not
in themselves an entirely
accurate representation,
they're a piece.
Talking to the old
musicians, that you may recall
in the film we interviewed the
three oldest Blues musicians I
the world -- Robert
Lockwood and Honey Boy
and Holmes @. I think
it was '98.
And Lockwood made it clear
that those musicians would have
repertoires for white audiences,
as well as black audiences,
and that they were very fluent
in country music and music that
would appeal to white audiences.
Obviously, there
are white audiences
that enjoyed listening
to Blues, as well.
And I think that those
issues are implicit in a film
and being in that environment.
I mean there's a moment
that I was discouraged
by the broadcast
they put in the film,
which was when Charlie
Patton's relatives go to Dockery
and they meet Bill Lester,
who is the owner of Dockery,
and there is this interesting
and uncomfortable conversation
where the current curator
of a plantation is telling
the history of their relative
to them on a plantation
where the family worked.
And I felt that that scenario
was enough to tell you
about the interesting
and uncomfortable
situation at that time.
However, the most
important thing
that the film is really about,
and it's certainly the heart
of what I've, we've come to feel
making this film and traveling
across America and meeting all
these people, I mean hundreds,
is that music is the one
thing that unites the races.
Music is like the, it
is the communication
that transcends everything
else, and it's music
that actually brings people
together and it's music
that puts an African-American
in a white person's home before
any government decree or law
or any book or newspaper.
It's a record that
brings those out
and the record brings
those ideas
and those feelings
into someone's home.
And how we appreciate other
cultures generally is first
through music.
I mean before Reggae
took off with Bob Marley,
most people could have written
what they knew about Jamaica
on the back of a postage stamp.
It was music that made an
awareness of the West Indies,
that's how we hear
about those cultures.
And because generally
film doesn't,
from other cultures
doesn't penetrate
to the same degree
popular music does.
So I think music was
actually something
that brought these
cultures together,
and they're all listening
and playing with each other.
I'm always bemused
by the kind of some
of the really weird theories you
read in books about this person
and this person, it's
not as clean as that,
everything is bleeding
one into the other.
I mean you could certainly make
a strong case that there's a lot
of Irish folk music in Blues,
and if you talk to someone
like Taj he would
absolutely agree with you.
He would also probably
say that there's a lot
of Native American music
in some of the delta Blues
because there was a lot
of Native American blood
within the people, like Patton,
that were making that music.
So there really is
a huge comingling,
I mean every single
African-American Blues performer
was a massive fan
of Jimmy Rogers,
I mean they all had
Jimmy Rogers records.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: You saw
Jimmy Rogers' records were
advertised in all the
African-American newspapers
at the time.
So there's a big crossover.
It's just the thing that fools
people is it's not always the
people that you would think,
liking the things
you would think.
I remember years
ago meeting some
of these early Hip-hop
artists from the '80s
and they basically thought
Gary Newman was a God,
Gary Newman and [inaudible].
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Now they're not
into some white dude
that's doing soul music,
they're into a white guy that's
doing some robotic schtick
that is about as far away
from African-American
culture as you can get.
And we tend to be drawn to
things that are really different
and look different
from what we know.
And so I think it was -- I
just thought it was amusing
that there was that, that
there's always been a comingling
of those cultures
and those ideas.
So I kind of think that
was really it for me.
The film is about saying all
these radically different
cultures are in the same
country, that's why America is
such an incredible
and beautiful place.
And we had actually the most
wonderful luckiest experience
of a lifetime to be able to
travel in a really deep way
through all these
different bits of America.
And I decided to go,
when you get from --
when you travel from New York
through the Appalachians,
you know, down into Mississippi,
Louisiana, Texas, Hopi,
then over to Hawaii, the idea
that one person in Washington,
D.C., the President of
all this, is mindboggling.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
Yes, absolutely.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
It is staggering
that all this is actually
under this is one country.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And
that's an incredible thing.
And, as we said, when you
travel America you see parts
of old Britain, where
we came from, untouched.
And you see people with old
British cultures, you know?
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Yes.
>> Allison McGourty:
Especially in South Carolina
when I was down there.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: I hear,
too, in West Virginia.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: I
wanted to bring up,
maybe this is a good time, the
importance of gospel music.
It's kind of central, essential
-- can you talk to that?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well,
it's spiritual and I think
that spiritual music has a
power to it and an energy
and a passion that
you can't approximate
in the secular world.
And I think an example
people will appreciate,
I grew up listening to
little Reggae music as a kid
and since the Rastafarianism
the religion has gone
out of the music and it's become
dancehall I just don't think the
music has anywhere near
the same commercial
and global reach it once did.
What people were drawn to,
people didn't really
understand Rastafarianism,
but they were drawn to the
spirituality of the music,
the fact that the
people singing it,
whether it was Winston
Rodney and Burning Spear,
or Bob Marley, had this
absolutely unshakeable passion
and belief in what
they are projecting.
And that spiritual belief is
even more powerful than being
in love with your partner,
it's a higher thing.
And so I think these preachers
in the south were fundamental
to the emancipation of the
African-American people,
as they told me,
and those preachers,
those church services
would last the entire day.
I'm repeating what Ted and
the guys there would tell me.
And a lot of the time people at
Birch would be up in the pulpit
and they would be talking
about issues, social issues
that related to them
and being proud
and standing up for themselves.
I mean Birch came back and he --
we met an old lady that was too
old to interview for the film,
she was like 98, wasn't she?
>> Allison McGourty: Yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
And she remembered Birch
in the '20s building the church,
when she was a little
girl, with his bare hands.
And so he would be standing
up and he would be the person
that would be putting
forward those ideas
about how there was equality
was needed, how people needed
to stand up, how they needed to,
and the church was their
inspiration in that.
And you can see,
if you're trying
to track these people
down, when you're looking
through the African-American
papers,
like the Pittsburgh Courier
and the Chicago Defender,
all these people that Levy
Bird and Birch is speaking
to each other in these
columns in the paper
and those newspapers,
most people were
distributing those newspapers,
like Levy Bird, in Turola, they
were getting those papers sent
and they were distributing
them on street corners
because they wanted their
fellow people to hear those,
read those words and find out
what was going on in the cities.
I think the church, it
was incredibly important
for those people, and
I think in the kind
of secular era we're living
in now I think it's easy
to forget how important
that spirituality can be.
And I think, Dizzy says in his
book, I think he says something
like the closest to the New
Testament is those sanctified
churches, which although
churches look
down when people are really
losing and getting into it.
But if you go, if
you see those kind
of performances you
just get swept up in it.
I mean when we filmed, when
we got all the Triumph choir,
members in the Triumph choir
from around America to come
to the little church, it was
really difficult to film it
because it's really
hard to concentrate
on shooting something
when that's going
off in front of you.
It's so explosive, the
emotion that you have
to be constantly
pinching yourself
to remind yourself
to stay on point.
So I think gospel music is,
it's in the very kind of rubric
of all good contemporary
music, that it's not a --
it's a commonly known thing that
a lot of the greatest rhythm
and Blues music came from
people being in the church
and singing in the church.
And people sing better being in
churches, people that have sung
in churches sing better
because they learned to sing
out from a young age,
so you project better.
So I think even on a
practical physical, therefore,
the church makes better singers.
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: So one of
the reasons why we were keen
to have you at The
Library of Congress
and to show your film here
and to talk about the film was
that there's footage from
our collections in the film.
And I'm going to tell a
little bit of the story
of some footage, which
then you'll pick-up on
and tell the rest of it.
So this is footage
of Honey Boy Edwards,
whom you've already mentioned,
who passed away a
few years ago sadly.
But this footage was made
by Alan Lomax in 1942
when he was doing
recording for The Library
of Congress in Mississippi.
And he brought along a silent
film camera, color film,
and he filmed some of the
artists that he recorded.
And out of this footage he put
together a demonstration reel
that he would take
around and show to people
about what he had
done in Mississippi,
and other people brought this
demonstration reel around,
as well.
And over time this reel got
very ratty and the color faded,
and it was labeled and we don't
know who did the labeling,
it was back in the 1940s.
It could have been
Alan, himself,
but it was probably
someone else.
And so the individual segments
of this film were labeled
and one of them was
labeled, Charles Edwards,
which was not Honey
Boy Edwards' name,
his name was David Edwards.
And so we just assumed
that this was film
of some buy named
Charles Edwards,
which would not have been
that significant necessarily
in the history of
American music.
But at some point our curator
of the Lomax Collection,
whose name is Tod Harvey,
whom you met a little earlier,
Tod had this insight and it was
actually I was the person he was
talking to, we were sitting in
the reading room and he said
to me, why would Lomax film
this guy playing the guitar
but then not record his
music, there's no recordings
from anyone named Charles
Edwards in the collection?
And I said, you know,
that's a really good point.
And we both sort of said, you
don't think they could be?
Nah, couldn't be.
[laughter] Because
Honey Boy had gone
on to be a Grammy winning artist
and Blues Hall of Fame and one
of the great Blues artists of
the 20th and 21st Centuries.
So we, so I started, I wouldn't
let this go, I kind of went
and did a little legwork
and I started reading both
Lomax' accounts of his meetings
with Honey Boy and
Honey Boy's accounts
because he wrote
an autobiography.
And the reason this was
difficult to determine was
that there was no other
picture of Honey Boy known
for 25 years after this event.
Even Honey Boy in his
own book had no pictures
of himself to print.
So his appearance had just
changed a lot in those 25 years
and it was not immediately
obvious that this was him.
But I started to read these
accounts and the hat was right
and the thumb pick was right,
and the guitar was right,
and I said this has got
to be Honey Boy Edwards.
So we bundled the film
together, we got a good transfer
from the original which
looks beautiful, as you know,
and we sent it to Michael Frank
who had been Honey Boy's sideman
and manager for many years.
Unfortunately, Honey Boy had
just died a year before we made
this, we had this insight.
But we sent it to Michael
and Michael showed it
to Honey Boy's stepdaughter
and he communicated to us
that her immediate phrase
on seeing this film was,
that's my daddy, and
so that's how we knew
that that was Honey Boy.
And then we were really tickled
when you used this footage
in the film, so explain how you
used it because you synched it
up amazingly with
Honey Boy's music,
so explain how you used it and
how you found out about it?
>> Bernard MacMahon: We
were, one of the things
that got American Epic
started was Michael Frank.
A friend of ours, Garth Cartra
@, who I mentioned earlier,
had approached us
and said you know
that these three Blues men
are coming to a festival
in the Lake District to play
and nobody knows about it,
it's run by some wealthy
guy and he just brings
in Blues musicians he likes
and doesn't do any
national promotion,
it's just the locals come.
And he wanted to have these
three oldest Blues musicians,
and so I had found out that
Michael Frank looked after all
of them -- Lockwood,
Homesick and Honey Boy.
So I called Michael and said,
could we come up and film them?
Money will change
hands if need be.
And he said, sure.
You know, I said,
when are they free?
He said, they're completely
free, no one knows we're here.
[laughter] Far from the gig.
And so that's, I'm sure
that's how I met Michael
and spent this entire
day with all three
of them interviewing each of
them for a couple of hours each
and then I think an hour or so
with all three of them together
and we use a part
of that in the film.
And so then when you made this
discovery, which is amazing.
This is very strange having
this interview because this is
like the genesis of the
project full circle, basically.
>> Allison McGourty: Wow.
>> Bernard MacMahon: So
that's the very beginning
of the whole American
Epic research was that,
doing that interview.
I did that because I thought
this needs to be filmed
and one day I'll probably
need it, that's why I shot it.
>> Stephen Winick: And
I'm really glad you did
because Honey Boy is gone.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick:
And, you know?
>> Bernard MacMahon: And on
top of it there's three guys,
so the mountains of
other stuff they talked
about was just incredible.
I'd just love to -- I think
one day I'd like to put
that up online so
people can just watch it,
it's really hilarious and
they go all over the place.
I mean all these musicians
they knew, but anyway.
So Michael called
me and he told me
that you'd made this discovery
and that he knew we were going
to do a piece, this is
after you'd found it,
and said I can speak to
The Library of Congress
and get permission for you
to use it in your film.
So I was kind of over the
moon that this had turned up,
and then I spoke to Tod.
And it just seemed to --
it was like one of those
moments it just seemed to good
to be true, it seemed staggering
that someone had shot this.
>> Stephen Winick: It seemed
too good to be true to us.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: And Tod
really had that great insight
that it's got to
be something other
than what it appears to be.
>> Bernard MacMahon: So
it had something about it.
As I said, you would have
thought it had been done the
same day he'd been
recorded, but it wasn't.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And I
don't know where I heard this,
but I was told that when Lomax
was shooting him he wanted
to record him and that
Honey Boy had said something
to the effect, I'm making too
much money on this corner,
come back another time, and
they arranged another time.
But I don't know where I -- I
have to say it wasn't germane
to the film and I just don't
remember where I heard this,
but generally these
things power out,
I remember they stick
in my mind.
However, I got a hold
of all the recordings
that Lomax had made
shortly after he shot that.
I think, was it a
week or two later?
>> Stephen Winick:
I think it was, yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And
I hired a lipreader to try
and decipher what he was
singing, couldn't do it,
and then I hired another
lipreader, couldn't do it,
then I hired another
lipreader, they couldn't do it.
I got five lipreaders,
all of whom I paid,
until eventually I
found a lipreader
that identified two
words that he was saying.
And that, I went back to the
tapes and I went, oh, my God,
this is from Army Blues, one
of the songs he recorded,
he was actually singing
one of the songs.
And so an engineer,
Peter Henderson, who said
and I think it's Army Blues
and I think the other
one is called West Coast,
was it Waterfront -- it was
Water Blues or something,
there's a fragment of that.
Because he's taking
different clips.
>> Stephen Winick: Right,
yes, he shot the camera.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Two songs,
the bulk of it is Army Blues.
All right, Peter Henderson, who
worked on a lot of the sound
for American Epic, is a genius,
won his first Grammy at 21,
and he's a wonderful guy, huge
important figure in this film
in terms of like always guiding
us in the right approach.
And I said, Peter, you
need to synch this.
And he went, you've
got to be kidding?
[laughter] And he just, he said,
this guy has never
played the same song
in the same way twice
in his life.
But he did a really
amazing job of that.
>> Stephen Winick:
A real good job.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Yes, he does.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
And so basically he's
playing the same song.
And so it was incredible, it was
like this really amazing moment.
>> Stephen Winick:
Yes, it's funny --
well, I mean that he was playing
Army Blues, which was very much
on his mind because when
Lomax met him he was going off
to be drafted, and the reason
that Lomax lost touch with him
for many, many years
was that he assumed
that he had been drafted but, in
fact, he managed to talk his way
out of the draft by
claiming an injury.
And that injury is a dent in his
head that he got from being hit
by a bottle of soda
that was thrown at him,
and that dent is one of the
ways that people were able
to identify that this
actually was footage of him.
So it all goes around.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Oh,
that's incredible, yes.
And then what was wonderful
there was all this other
beautiful footage
that you transferred
of kids dancing nearby,
which we also used
at the end of the film.
And there's something
very touching about that,
those young African-American
girls dancing in the field.
And I love old photographs
of people happy decades
and decades ago and wondering
what happened to them.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon: There's
an innocence about it.
Yes, it's very emotional.
So for that reason we
decided in the film
that there were quite a lot
of dissolves between stills
from the '20s and '30s, and
then we dissolved a footage
of that same place.
So we were all the time tramping
around where we were doing
the interviews, is take --
I remember our line producer
would be constantly tamping his
watch and we were trying to
find the exact location of where
that still had been taken
so I could match the frame
and that you could dissolve, so
that people could see how places
in America looked then
and how they look now.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And so
that's kind of the metaphor
for walking by and just or
as you walked past every door
and every street just
thinking for a minute what
that building may have housed
80 years ago, 100 years,
who might have been in there and
what they might have been doing.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: It's a
great segway to the question
of how you melded
archival footage,
I mean you said one way,
dissolve into the
contemporary footage,
but I'm sure there are
other ways that you worked
with both contemporary and
archival footage in the film?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well,
we developed a new technique
that we invented for using
archival footage, that a couple
of really sharp cinematographers
have spotted.
But most people just go,
it looks really nice,
and they don't actually
know why.
[laughter]
>> Stephen Winick:
That would be me.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Now
it's all scanned at really,
really high resolution,
sometimes as high as 8K.
We went to great
efforts to ensure
that everything was original
prints so that it felt
as tangible as possible,
like the music.
But what we did with the
archive footage is one
of the issues you have with
historical documentaries is,
and you see this in all of
them, they do something --
on a film the aspect ratio,
which is the shape of the image,
has changed over the years.
And now we were in a sort of
letterbox format for a film,
but in the '20s and into
the '50s we were dealing
with a 4-3 aspect ratio,
which is essentially
more like a square.
And so what filmmakers
have done in documentaries
since there were documentaries
in the modern format is
they punch into the footage,
now that is to say they zoom
into the footage so that
that image fills
the whole screen.
And I'm not knocking it,
if that's what you like,
but you are basically losing
a massive amount of what
that original cameraman
framed up.
And I think in historical things
and in everything
context is everything,
you need to see the
whole picture.
So I like total truth
in documentaries,
so I mean my view is
just you have the people,
the family talking, you see the
real photographs and you show
as much of everything
as possible.
So what we did is we did a
technique called over-scanning,
which is where we scan the
entire film showing the frame.
So this would normally
be cut-off,
so you see the curved
edges of the frame.
And then we would scan
the leader of the film,
which is like the black
leader which is the celluloid
or the nitrate before you get
to the film, before you get
to the actual images, and
that would be superimposed
at the side of the screen, so
you actually have the grain
of that film at the
side of the screen.
So basically the picture is
never retracting and expanding
as it would when you're moving
from contemporary footage
to old footage, it is
always full screen.
So you're not only seeing the
entirety of the '20s picture
with no cropping, in
fact, you're seeing more
than you would be seeing
when it was projected
because there would have been
some cropping of those edges,
but also the entire
picture is breathing.
And so we devised that
technique to use this material
so that we could
constantly move in and out
of the old and the new.
And that was it really.
And then the other thing is
just a sense of momentum.
We shot the whole -- I
shot all the interviews,
much to the chagrin
of my cinematographer,
on a slider or a dolly.
That is a device that
allows the camera
to move from left to right.
And so this gentle movement
is happening, but the idea is
to mimic the feeling of
the way your head looks
when you're staring at somebody.
If you're in a situation
of conversation
with somebody your head is
not held by a metal clamp
so you're unmoving,
and you are moving
and your constantly
looking around
and at the sides of the people.
So the sense was that not
more, yes, so essentially it's
to mimic the feeling as if I
was standing on a porch talking
to somebody, I would be looking
at them slightly from the left
and right and it's to mimic
that feeling of being there,
but it also creates
a sense of momentum
which interestingly enough
blends the old footage
with the new footage and
the old footage better.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Interesting.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
That's fascinating to me.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
That's just tricks
of the trade I've never
talked about before.
[laughter]
>> Stephen Winick: Well, I
think we're probably running low
on time, so we should talk
very briefly about some
of the related products
that you've come out with
in addition to the film, itself.
One thing that really
interests me is the box set,
which you talked
about the influence
of the Harry Smith
anthology in the film
and this is sort of
a similar concept.
How did you conceptualize
the set?
>> Bernard MacMahon: Well,
the set is 100, maybe 100,
as I mentioned 100 groups
or musicians were researched
for the film across all these
different genres of music.
I wanted American Epic
to have all the kinds
of indigenous music in it
that other sets before
hadn't included.
And so the Hispanic, the
African-American, the Hawaiian,
I wanted all those things
to be in it because they're
such an important
part of the mix,
and so are the Native American.
And so in doing that and looking
at the artists that should be
in the film we came
up with the idea
of having what we
thought were the hundreds
of the most powerful songs,
performances from that era.
It was a method of having
something people would really
dive into and they could
experience just how colorful
this period was.
And this is really a metaphor
for how we should
be proceeding today.
I mean what they were doing then
is what should be happening now.
We should be embracing
that level.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
And actually the doorway has
become much more restricted
since that time in terms of what
gets in and what gets in front
of the public or what's
available to the public.
And so this was a method
of saying here is hundreds
of the greatest parts.
And American Epic is
a film, it's not --
it's what we would
describe as nondidactic.
It's not a scientific project,
it's an emotional response
to music and a culture
that we love
and it's basically the reason,
it's the reason why
we love America.
It's two bricks in one American,
putting on to film what we love
about America, and we're
doing it at the point
when America really kind of
explodes and comes into its own,
which is the '20s, and the world
is still kind of in the throw
of what America developed
in the '20s.
And so those songs, when you
watch the American Epic films,
the visual metaphor we use
to convey how the film is being
approached is an old record
album is kind of pulled off the
shelf and we see the book open,
and these were those
old leather-bound books
that people would
put their records in.
>> Stephen Winick: Albums.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes, that's
where the term album comes from,
like a photo album except
you had your records in it.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
And years later,
a few years later record
companies got the idea why don't
you put someone's photograph
and have all one
person's records in there.
But before then you'd buy
these leather-bound books
and you'd put your singles,
if you will, in that
and that would become
your record album.
And so you see that book
turning and you see the records
and we zoom in on a record
and we hear the story behind
that record, some are an
artist you might have heard
or many you will
never have heard.
And the idea that
we're suggesting is
that there are hundreds of
thousands of these records
and here are 10 of
these stories, go forth
and explore yourself, because
behind every one there may be a
story like this.
And so the book, the box set,
is a method of going into 100
of those things and you
can start to extrapolate
from looking at the film what
the stories are about those.
So the box set has I think
it has lyrics transcribed
for all the songs, which many
have never been transcribed
before, and again in an
emotional response as opposed
to historical we have quotes
from the artists or their family
about every single one, that
was incredibly hard to find
that once you said, oh, we're
going to do this for everyone.
It was really difficult,
and stills for most of them,
I mean there's many,
many people in there
that music fans have
never seen before.
But the big breakthrough
is the sound.
>> Stephen Winick: Yes, I
wanted to talk about that, yes?
>> Bernard MacMahon: That's
a huge part of American Epic.
In a music film or any film
sound is 50% of a movie,
and yet sound is often a big
neglected part of features,
it's like a poor cousin,
it's a thing that's generally
tossed off at the end.
And so here when we had the
Western Electric recording
system and Nick Burger
and Ginny had got
that machine working we recorded
all the contemporary artists
on it first.
What was amazing was
that I suddenly could hear
how the old records might have
sounded because I was
hearing Willie Nelson
or Elton John on that machine.
I in my mind's ear hear how
John Hurt was meant to sound,
how those records
might have sounded,
because we were the first
people in almost 80 years
that were using this machinery
that made those records.
And so I said, spoke to Nick and
said, look, how would you feel
about doing some serious R
and D work using what we've
learned recording this
to transfer these records?
And Nick being the highly
professional individual he is
kind of put that off for
months and months and months,
but he was -- he was actually
doing it, he just didn't want
to say he was going to do it
until he figured he could make
a significant improvement.
And he said, okay, I'll do it,
but he'd actually
figured it out.
And so he was able to
transfer these old records
and bring things out in them
that we never heard before,
but the main thing is
they were really musical,
the transfer sounded
really, really musical.
They had a kind of
musicality and nuance
to them I'd never heard
and there were songs,
these songs were
making me feel things
that I had never felt before.
And so we asked him
to get involved
in transferring all the disks
for the compilation,
as well as the film.
And what I noticed I'd never
heard before is that the trouble
with the '20s music is that
the disks they recorded
to were often so gnarly and
it's so difficult for people
to know how to play them back
that the problem you have is
after four or five songs
your ears get really tired
and you can't listen to
any more and you want
to put a modern recording
on that's made on
tape or something.
Here, on this box set, you
don't have that affect anymore,
you can just listen to the song,
song after song, they just roll
into each other because they
have a musicality of flow
to them but they
also have a clarity.
And so the engineers, Peter
Henderson and Joel Teftella @,
they did just insane amounts
of work manually removing all
the clicks from these records
without putting them through
processing and stuff like this.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
That's amazing.
>> Bernard MacMahon: So
everything sounds very open,
like there's lots of air,
you can really hear the room,
you can just when you hear the
recordings you can hear the
sound of the record, the
performance as it echoes
around the room that
they're in recording it.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: And you
actually have before and after
of the recording to kind
of compare the improvement?
>> Allison McGourty: Yes.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
I mean, yes, you can,
we can play an example of one of
these disks how they would sound
like if you transferred
them on a normal turntable
and then we can play an
example of how they would sound,
how they sound like now
when they've been
transferred to the system.
And, yes, so then --
>> Allison McGourty: And then
we can play a reimagined version
where we rerecord the song
in the present day
on the same machine.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
the contemporary, doing that.
But, yes, so there are 12,
I think 12 album releases,
there's the box set,
there's a soundtrack,
and then there are 10 artists
and genre compilations.
So there's all of John
Hurt's recordings,
a selection of the
Memphis Jug Band stuff.
Yes, it's pretty --
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
It's productive.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
it's very -- yes, yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: And you
have your companion book, too,
a beautiful, beautiful companion
book with all these photographs,
it felt like a scrapbook
that's kind of done up right.
[laughter]
>> Bernard MacMahon: And, yes.
>> Stephen Winick:
An award-winning
book we should say.
>> Allison McGourty:
Yes, thank you.
Yes, we wanted to let the
reader feel like they were
on the journey with us,
understanding how Bernard did
the research and what it was
like to be traveling across
America, meeting these people.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes,
that's like kind of the --
we get asked a lot about making
the films, and so the book is --
I mean all the parts are meant
to be really essentially
somewhat exclusive,
so that's really the insight of
how everything was put together
and it's an opportunity
to tell a lot
of stories you can't
tell in a film, but yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
And Elijah Walt.
>> Allison McGourty:
Oh, he's wonderful, yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: You
worked with him on the book.
>> Bernard MacMahon:
Elijah is fantastic.
He's like a scientist
with words.
He's really, he was really
helpful, he came in and went
through the iteration before
we went to see Redford
with it and recorded it.
And Elijah has got a
wonderfully acute eye and ear
for exactly what the
sentence is saying.
Because here, I mean you
raised this thing about this,
the question about the
slide guitar earlier
and where it came from,
and I just presented the
information that we found.
I think it's not possible
to be absolutely right
on any of these things.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Bernard MacMahon: And so
there are statements you have
to make in a film where
as emotionally to try
to tell a story and people
in the room is we have
to steer the audience
room to room.
And Elijah was very helpful in
having a line of iteration not
to say more than it
was meant to say.
Yes.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: That's key.
>> Bernard MacMahon: It's
really, it's very important.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: We
know this in radio.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Yes, yes.
Anything else?
>> Stephen Winick: No.
>> Mary Sue Twohy:
Well, let's see.
I think we covered
a lot of ground.
>> Stephen Winick: I think
we've covered a lot of ground.
>> Mary Sue Twohy: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: And I
think we have to get you
over to the soundtrack so that
you can actually get your movie
screened tonight.
>> Bernard MacMahon: Okay.
>> Stephen Winick: So, once
again, these are the Producers
and Director and
Writer of American Epic,
which was a series of films
that became a series on PBS.
Mary Sue Twohy from
SiriusXM Radio,
and my name is Steve Winick,
I work here at The Library
of Congress in the
American Folklife Center.
Thanks very much.
>> Allison McGourty: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.